welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's webinar
vulnerability to stress as a risk factor
for major mental disorders presented by
dr. Anthony grace distinguished
professor of neuroscience professor of
psychiatry and psychology department of
neuroscience university of pittsburgh my
name is alexis Kraus and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lappers
laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before you begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate bay submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box our speaker will respond
to your questions via email following
the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're experiencing
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now
without further ado please join me in
welcoming dr. grace I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you for
the introduction what I'm going to be
talking about is the work that we've
been doing looking at animal models
related to schizophrenia and other major
mental disorders now of course when you
talk about something as uniquely human
as schizophrenia something like that
can't be exactly modeled in an animal
model but what we hope the show is by
taking information from the clinical
literature and going back and forth
between the animal model and the
clinical literature we think that we can
actually look at some of the circuitry
and pathways in pharmacology that are
common between the systems now in
talking with schizophrenia one of the
important things to focus on is the
dopaminergic system this is the dopamine
system in the rat consisting of the
we'll take mental area on the left and
the substantia [ __ ] on the right of
course in the primate the ventral
tegmental area is smaller it actually
moves over to become the dorsal aspect
of the substantia [ __ ] and the ventral
aspect the substantia [ __ ] the
dopaminergic system has been linked to a
number of disorders we know that the
substantia [ __ ] dopaminergic neurons or
ventral tear degenerate in Parkinson's
disease the most medial part of the
ventral tegmental area that's involved
in emotion or effect tends to have a
role in drug abuse and depression and
schizophrenia it tends to be the more
lateral part of the ventral tegmental
area that has a major involvement in
things like salience and seems to be
disrupted in schizophrenia now in order
to study this in an animal what we want
to do is to be able to record from the
population of dopaminergic neurons now
how do we determine the overall state of
activity of these neurons in the brain
of the living Rath well we know we can
record from single neurons but that
really doesn't give us a complete
picture of what's going on because we
know some neurons are firing
spontaneously and some are inhibited and
non firing and the ones that are firing
or firing at different rates and
patterns so what we do is to pass an
electrode through the ventral tegmental
area and a preset pattern and count the
number of neurons that we see firing
spontaneously and this is a measure of
population activity then when we isolate
a neuron we see how fast it's firing or
its firing rate and also its firing
pattern and we do this because all of
these parameters are controlled by
different circuits and have different
behavioral impacts on the organism with
respect to firing pattern dopaminergic
neurons are known to fire in a slow
irregular firing pattern at baseline but
studies by Wolfram Schultz and others
have shown that whenever an animal is
exposed to behaviorally salient stimulus
dopaminergic neurons fire bursts of
action potentials so these bursts are
really the rapid phasic behaviorally
salient output of the dopamine system
first firing alerts the brain that an
important event has happened burst
firing is controlled
glutamate urging inputs coming from a
brainstem area called the Pinocchio
pontine tegmentum or PPT G this plans on
NMDA receptors on dopaminergic neurons
and causes the dopaminergic neurons to
go into a burst firing mode of the thing
about NMDA receptors is the neuron has
to be depolarized in order for them to
be activated if the neuron is
hyperpolarized or non firing there's a
magnesium block of the NMDA channel so
nothing happens so only the firing
neurons can burst fire which raises the
question about what causes or what
regulates whether a neuron is firing or
not this seems to be potently regulated
by the ventral pallidum the ventral
pallidum is a GABAergic area it's the
ventral aspect of the Globus pallidus it
provides a potent inhibitory input to
the dopaminergic neurons to keep them
from firing when this area is inhibited
it removes this inhibition from the
dopaminergic neurons and allows them to
start firing at their normal rate and
pattern now what's the relevance of
whether a neuron is firing or not it
basically provides a level of
amplification of the system so as I
mentioned the ventral pallidum controls
whether it's firing but I feel the
pontine causes firing neurons to the
first fire burst firing is the signal
but the ventral pallidum controls the
gain or the amplification of the signal
the more neurons that are firing the
more that you're going to get a more
neurons are going to go into a burst
firing mode and this system seems to
play a major role particularly in the
psychotic symptoms of schizophrenia now
in order to try to understand this what
we used is a developmental neurotoxin
methylase oxy methanol acetate or ma'am
we know that schizophrenia patients
whenever the mother is in a dangerous or
disruptive situation while pregnant for
example when they're in a area of famine
during the second trimester when they
have a severe influenza infection during
the second trimester there's a higher
incidence
schizophrenic Birds suggesting that this
is really a critical very sensitive
period so what we do is to give the man
a DNA alkylating agent at gestational
days 17 which is roughly equivalent to
the human second trimester we then let
the rats be born follow them through
adolescence to adulthood and see what
happens
when we get to the adult we see a number
of things that recapitulate what we
would expect for an animal model of
schizophrenia
as far as the anatomy we see a thinning
of the limbic cortical structures not a
major thinning only about 10 to 20
percent about what you see in humans and
it's the same equivalent structures that
you see thinned in human post-mortem
schizophrenia brains but there is no
loss of a large number of neurons
instead the neurons are packed closer
together so you lose neuro pill rather
than substantial loss of number of
neurons but one class of neurons that is
loss are the PP or parvalbumin
containing GABAergic neurons that are
seen in the animal model as well as in
schizophrenia patients we also see
disruptions of behavior such as sensory
gating like pre pulse inhibition of
startle deficits and prefrontal cortical
function or executive function such as
reversal learning or extra dimensional
shift and impairments with respect to
negative symptoms such as latent
inhibition and social interaction we
also find that the animals tend to be
hyper responsive to certain drugs as are
schizophrenia patients we know for
example that PCP or phencyclidine can
mimic the psychosis that schizophrenia
patients feel and we also see an
increased response in the rats we also
see an exacerbation of the locomotor
effects of amphetamine in the adult mam
treated rats interestingly we don't see
it pre-pubertal II which is consistent
with schizophrenia arising in the late
adolescent early adulthood phase in
humans
now the increased FM immune response is
consistent with a role for dopamine in
schizophrenia
we know that there's a lot of evidence
for a role for dopamine and
schizophrenia all antipsychotic drugs in
use today are primarily dopaminergic
antagonists or occupied dopamine d2
receptors drugs that release dopamine
such as FN amine and l-dopa well worsen
psychotic symptoms in schizophrenia
patients and have given it high enough
doses can mimic schizophrenia and
normals and we know that schizophrenia
patients show an increased FN Amin
induced dopamine release this is
measured by looking at binding of
radioactively-labeled rakla pride which
is a low affinity dopamine antagonists
which can be displaced from receptors by
endogenous dopamine and what we find is
a much greater displacement than
schizophrenia patients and furthermore
the amplitude of this increase
correlates with the ability of
amphetamine to worsen psychosis so we
have an identity between a
over-activated dopaminergic system and
at least the psychotic symptoms of
schizophrenia the thing is despite years
of looking there hasn't been evidence
for a primary deficit in the dopamine
system itself instead we now believe the
dopamine system is normal but is likely
dysregulated by other structures and one
that's gotten a lot of attention is the
hippocampus which imaging studies and
schizophrenia patients has been shown to
be hyperactive especially during the
psychotic phase so this is the
hippocampus hyperactive in the mam
animal as it is in patients with
schizophrenia well when we look at just
firing the ventral or limbic hippocampus
what we find is the tends to be firing
significantly faster in the mam rat
compared to the controls but what's
interesting is not only is it firing
faster but it's rhythmic act area that
activity is disrupted now instead of the
low frequency rhythms that are necessary
for gating information flow in other
structures these frequencies are lost
and are replaced by an increase in a
higher frequency rhythms so if anything
there's more high-frequency noise coming
out of the hippocampus overdriving
postsynaptic circuits
not as this impact dopaminergic neuron
activity well when we look at our three
parameters of dopaminergic neuron
activity number of neurons firing firing
rate and pattern what we find in the
man-animals
is a nearly doubling in the number of
dopaminergic neurons firing without a
change in average firing rate or firing
pattern now this is actually consistent
with what's been seen clinically studies
by housing McGuire in London have shown
that in ultra high risk subjects in
schizophrenia patients there's an
increased Florida but up taking the
dopaminergic terminals now fluorodopa is
a measure of metabolic activity that
suggests that there are more terminals
active in the schizophrenia patient
stratum which is consistent with our
results showing more dopaminergic
neurons firing and driving those
terminals so when the hippocampus is
hyperactive it can overdrive the ventral
stratum nucleus accumbens this then
inhibits the ventral pallidum and causes
the dopaminergic neurons to begin firing
now we know that this is occurring but
because of the hippocampal hyperactivity
because if we inactivate the ventral
hippocampus it brings the number of
dopaminergic neurons firing back to
normal without affecting the other
parameters and then when we look at
behavior the increase in amphetamine
induced locomotion we see in the mam
rats whenever we inactivate the
hippocampus brings through amphetamine
induced locomotion back to the baseline
control levels so hippocampal overdrive
leading to increased dopaminergic neuron
population activity we think is the
basis for the dopamine hyper responsive
'ti that's seen in schizophrenia how
does this increase population activity
lead to the kind of symptoms that we
expect to see in schizophrenia patients
well one thing that the hippocampus does
is it's involved in context dependency
or the ability to adjust responses based
on the context in which stimuli are
presented so for example if you're in a
benign context
you're sitting at home in a safe
neighborhood behind locked doors you
feel safe and nothing bad is going to
happen the hippocampus has the system
toned out so not a lot of neurons are
firing you then hear a noise outside
that noise the behaviorally saline
stimulates stimulus activates the PP TG
and causes burst firing but because
there aren't a lot of dopaminergic
neurons firing the dopamine signal is
attenuated so you might turn around look
out the window and see what the noise
was in a calm manner but let's say
you're in an activating context you're
walking through a very dangerous part of
the neighborhood that you're an animal
out hunting where every noise is
something that you might be able to eat
or something to potentially eat you you
have to be very vigilant to every
stimulus that comes in now the
hippocampus has the system toned up
because of the activating context more
dopaminergic neurons firing now the same
noise is going to cause the same ppt
deactivation but because there's more
neurons firing you're going to get a
bigger dopamine response you're going to
rapidly orient towards the stimulus to
see if this is something that you could
take advantage of or something that you
need to escape from but what about the
schizophrenia patient in this case the
hippocampus is hyperactive it's over
driving the dopaminergic system so that
all the dopaminergic neurons are active
all the time independent of context now
whenever there's a noise whether it's
salient or not it's going to cause a
massive activation of the dopaminergic
system which means now every stimulus is
going to be activating the system as if
it were a threat that had to be dealt
with and this is something consistent
with what schizophrenia patients have
reported an excellent book by Ellen
sacks called the center cannot hold my
journey through madness describes her
experience with schizophrenia as being
constantly bombarded with stimuli where
the filter that tells you what to pay
attention to and what the safely ignore
is broken so that everything is flooding
in
it also can lead to a improper
attribution of importance to benign
objects so for example if you look
outside the window and see two strangers
talking to each other this is something
you know you can safely ignore but when
a schizophrenia patients needs this the
dopamine system causes a massive
activation as if that work this were a
threat and the patient has to come up
with reasons why they're feeling this
incredibly charged emotional response so
they can fabulet that these are aliens
planning to abduct them this is the
government spying on them something
should teach Gabor is referred to as
aberrant sailings or the improper
attribution of importance the stimuli
that should be ignored so when the
hippocampus is hyperactive the dopamine
system is hyper responsive to stimuli
and results in over interpretation of
events now as I mentioned the ventral
hippocampus is also involved in context
dependency which as I mentioned is also
disrupted in schizophrenia and in fact
when we look at this in rats we also
find a disruption so for example if you
have two contexts the different in shape
in the tone being emitted the color of
light and the odor of the two contexts
you expose one animal to a mild foot
shock in context a and nothing in
context B and as you would expect the
rat exposed to the shock contact text
would spend more time freezing whereas
when they're in the neutral context
they're not going to show much of a
response but mam rats don't show a
difference between the two contexts
interestingly if this is the same thing
seen in schizophrenia patients in the
bottom graph you see that when people
are put into a room where they've
received the negative stimulus the
controls feel more uneasy in areas where
they had the negative stimulus compared
to the neutral stimulus or schizophrenia
patients just like the mam rats don't
show a difference so these data show
that in the mam model of schizophrenia
ventral hippocampal hyperactivity leads
to a hyper responsive dopamine
system that we propose underlies
psychosis why is the hippocampus
hyperactive in schizophrenia well one of
the most robust findings that's been
reported in schizophrenia is a loss of a
particular type of GABAergic inhibitory
neurons those that contain the calcium
binding protein pelvic parvalbumin this
is seen this loss is seen in the
hippocampus and prefrontal cortex of
schizophrenia patients and similarly we
also see a decrease in the prefrontal
cortex and the ventral hippocampus of
the mam rats so we see this regionally
selective decrease in parvalbumin number
now how does this decrease in
parvalbumin interneurons effect
information processing well parvalbumin
neurons are known to affect high
frequency gamma rhythms they're known to
play a role in stimulus recognition and
processing and we know that there are a
disruption of BMI rhythms and psychosis
and schizophrenia as well as other
disorders so what we did is to examine
whether activity rhythms evoke buy
conditioned stimuli that cause these
gamma rhythms are also altered in brain
regions where you see a decrease in
parvo Beaman interneurons so to do this
we implant electrodes in the ventral
hippocampus and medial prefrontal cortex
and record local field potentials and
then break them up using a fast fourier
transform into delta theta beta and
gamma rhythms we then expose an animal
to either a neutral tone or a tone
associated with the foot shot and what
we find in the normal animal is that the
tone presented at the yellow bar causes
a gamma activation in the prefrontal
cortex and ventral hippocampus but in
the mam rats we don't get the gamma
activation so in areas where we lose our
Bell buna neurons we also lose the
ability to get this gamma activation so
what I've talked about is the ventral
hippocampus leading to an overactive
dopamine system which we think underlies
psychosis but we know the schizophrenia
is more than just psychosis
there's
so the cognitive symptoms and the
negative or affective symptoms and what
we find is that the ventral hippocampus
also projects to the amygdala which -
the cingulate and orbital frontal cortex
controls emotional responses it also
projects to the prefrontal cortex that's
involved in cognition so in the ventral
hippocampus is hyperactive and is
rhythmic it has the potential of pulling
down this entire circuit to lead to all
of the symptom classes of schizophrenia
so what we believe is that both in
schizophrenia and the mad model there's
hyperactivity in the ventral hippocampus
possibly due to decreased interneuron
function and if we inactivate the
ventral hippocampus we can restore a
normal don't need function now how can
we do this in the dopamine system of
schizophrenia patients well right now we
think that antipsychotic drugs are doing
this by acting on the dopamine system
the problem is we think the sign of the
deficit is this loss of parvalbumin
inhibition of the pyramidal neurons but
we treat schizophrenia by blocking
dopamine in the stratum which is one two
three four five synapses downstream from
where we think the problem is which
means that the antipsychotic drugs which
are really discovered by serendipity
rather than any kind of planned
synthesis probably aren't the best
mechanism for treating psychosis a
better approach would be to treat at the
site of pathology so this would involve
the parvalbumin inter neuron input into
the pyramidal neurons of the hippocampus
parvalbumin inter neurons are driven by
NMDA receptors which is probably where
PCP serves to worsen the psychotic
phenomenon what we would like to do is
to potentiate the effect of the
remaining parvalbumin neurons on the
pyramidal neurons now we can do this by
giving a benzodiazepine which
potentiated together the problem is it's
not selective now we know that
benzodiazepines are highly sedative so a
better approach would be if we can
somehow get a morsel
and benzodiazepine a benzodiazepines act
on the GABA a receptor specifically on
the alpha subunit and there is seven
different alpha subunits with different
pharmacology the alpha 1 and alpha 2 are
the senator subunits but the hippocampus
and amygdala are SEC that selectively
concentrated with the gaba a alpha 5
subunit so what we wanted to do is to
get a selective GABA a alpha 5
benzodiazepine and working with Jim cook
in Madison Wisconsin we came up with
such a drug one that very potent ly
inhibits activation of the hippocampus
but at the difference in apps like the
thalamic input to the cortex even 10
times the dose doesn't have an impact
what about when we look at the
dopaminergic system
well this drugs doesn't seem to have
much effect on control animals but on
the mam animals it brings the number of
dopaminergic neurons firing back to
baseline and it also brings the behavior
response to amphetamine back to baseline
so it's basically normalizing all these
parameters now you under these
conditions you might think well why
aren't there studies being done by
pharmaceutical companies to try to get
these drugs into clinical trials well
the problem is a number of drugs that
have shown promised preclinically have
failed in the clinic Lily had an M glue
our t 3 agonist bummer gloomy Todd that
look great in preclinical studies but
failed in the clinic Roche had a glycine
uptake inhibitor that look great in
preclinical studies failed in a clinic
Pfizer had a PDE 10 inhibitor look great
in preclinical studies failed in the
clinic so drugs designed to work
specifically on his deficit although
they look good pre clinically have all
failed to produce clinically effective
drugs the problem is is the difference
in the way these preparations are
treated the first drug that the mam
animal sees is the test drug but in
clean
trials they often take schizophrenia
patients that have been on antipsychotic
drugs for as long as decades withdraw
them for one week in order to wash out
the drug and then test the normal
compound the problem is is such
treatment with opening blocking drugs
are going to substantially alter the
system specifically like long term
blockade of dopamine receptors you're
going to get dopamine receptors super
sensitivity in fact when we look at our
ma'am animals and give them just three
weeks of the antipsychotic drug pala
paradol followed by one week withdrawal
what we find is our GABA compound that
works so beautifully on the left on the
right and the red bars fails to impact
the dopaminergic system even lesioning
the hippocampus doesn't impact the
dopamine system and when we look at the
behavioral effects what we find is the
sock in the solid red bar the
normalization of amphetamine locomotion
we see in the man animal with three
weeks of haloperidol in the red dashed
lines this normalization is completely
prohibited so haloperidol pretreatment
has altered the capacity of the system
to respond to a novel agent now whenever
you withdraw a dopamine blocking drug
the only thing that's going to work is
another dopamine blocking drug unless
you can either get non-compliant
patients or patients that are still at
the early stages of the disorder and
haven't received a long course of
antipsychotic treatment so in
schizophrenia and the mam model inter
neuron dysfunction may be a primary
drive of the symptomatology and if we
can restore inter neuron function we
should have an effective treatment
strategy the thing is we know that the
presence of schizophrenia is bad for the
brain
the longer the untreated psychosis the
worse the prognosis a better approach
would be as if we could prevent the
transition to psychosis to begin with
now how can we do this well there's
evidence that stress can play a a major
causative role in psychiatric disorders
we know that stressful stimuli in
patients with schizophrenia will
exacerbate the psychotic symptoms of the
disorder and patients that are
controlled by antipsychotic drugs that
are returned to a high-stress
environment are much more likely to
relapse furthermore studies by Yves
Johnston have shown that stress may play
a role in the etiology of schizophrenia
in studies where she looked at a number
of children that were at genetic risk
for schizophrenia based on family
history she did a number of psychometric
tests while they were adolescents and
then followed them up to see who
converted to schizophrenia and who
didn't and what she found are the
children that were hyper responsive
distress early in life tended to be the
ones that converted to schizophrenia and
the thing about stress is it can damage
carve albumin interneurons especially
early in life the premises and normal
individuals areas like the prefrontal
cortex can limit the impact of stress
exposure but if this system isn't
functioning the deficits can initiate a
cascade of events that magnify the
effects of stress that we think lead to
interneuron loss since it's a friendly
and the adults so in the normal adult
stress activates the mesocortical
dopamine system which releases dopamine
in the medial prefrontal cortex which
feeds back in and hits that stress
response but if this system is disrupted
it's going to disrupt dopaminergic
system regulation you're not going to
get the prefrontal cortical down
modulation of stress related areas like
the amygdala which is going to magnify
the impact of stress this is going to
activate the Norwich energic system and
the locus coeruleus which is going to
continue to contribute to stress believe
hypothalamic through the corticoid
release hippocampal damage and so forth
and a positive feedback loop where
stress causes damage which causes more
stress now are the mam rats more
sensitive de-stress errs especially
early in life before we're seeing any of
the other pathology
well what we found is that whenever we
looked at measures of anxiety and stress
and rats such as the elevated plus maze
elevated plus maze consists of open arms
and closed arms that are elevated above
the floor normal animals explore both
the opening closed arms but when an
animal is anxious it tends to hide in
the closed arms and that's what the mam
animals did so they were anxious also
whenever an animal is exposed to a mild
foot shock it tends to vocalize what we
find in the mam animals is they tend to
vocalize way more to a very mild shock
compared to the Saline animals which
means they're they're more responsive
distress errs in furthermore the basal
lateral amygdala an area that we know is
involved in stress regulation is
hyperactive in the mam animal which can
also contribute to the anxiety so all
three parameters of stress and anxiety
are elevated than the mam animal
now if stress plays a role in the
etiology of schizophrenia during
development this suggests that if we
intervene early enough consistent
susceptible individuals we might be able
to prevent this transition so we tested
this in the mam animal by administering
the anti-anxiety agent is a pet right
before puberty and then testing the
animals is built what we did is to
select the dose of diazepam that
normalized behavior in the elevated plus
maze and normalize the mingle and neuron
firing during this pre-pubertal state we
then tested it in the rats by giving
them just 10 days of diazepam right
around or before puberty then wait until
they reached adulthood and tested them
and what we found is that this blunted
the loss of parvalbumin interneurons and
it also prevented the act of over
activation of the dopaminergic system in
the ventral tegmental area as well as
prevented the amphetamine induced hyper
locomotion now of course now this
suggests that diazepam given to someone
before puberty has the potential of
preventing this psychosis however not
everybody that has a genetic risk for
schizophrenia is going to develop
schizophrenia later in life only 10 to
15 percent we certainly don't want to
give all these people guys a pen but a
better approach would be to do other
things to control stress and one thing
we did is to use environmental
enrichment by giving the animals more
social interaction more activities more
exercise and what we found that if we
give them this pre-pubertal
environmental enrichment we actually
prevented the activation of the
dopaminergic system that we see in the
adult a converging evidence from
clinical and basic science studies
suggests the inability to regulate
stress early in life can lead to
pathological changes in the hippocampus
that may underlie the emergence of
schizophrenia and the adult now
interestingly the fact that mam can be
circumvented suggests that mam doesn't
cause schizophrenia but instead
increases the impact of environmental
factors on disease susceptibility and
what we posit is the same thing might
happen for genetic predisposition to
schizophrenia but the genes don't cause
schizophrenia the genes cause an
increase in the impact of environmental
stressors on the hippocampal parvalbumin
system and it's this increased impact of
stress that leads to the disorder now if
this were true if an animal was stressed
enough during this pre-pubertal period
we could get the same parvalbumin loss
so what we did is instead of giving
diazepam to normal rats during this
postnatal day 31 to 40 we now tuck
normal rats and expose them to stress
during the same period either three
sessions of restrained stress
daily foot shock stress or combined foot
shock and restraint we then waited till
they reached adulthood and did various
tests what we found is that giving them
these stressors pre-puberty cause the
rats to be more anxious as adults we
also found that it tended to interfere
with their ability to perform a
cognitive tasks such as novel object
recognition where they can't seem to
tell the difference between an object
they've experienced previously and the
novel object that's taken its place but
only the combine for chocolate restraint
activated dopaminergic neuron firing and
activated the increase the locomotor
response to amphetamine but
interestingly the increase was located
exclusively in the lateral VTA now this
is important because the lateral VTA
projects to the associative stratum the
associative striatum are the places
where you see increased rakla pride
displacement and increased fluorodopa
uptake in the brains of schizophrenia
patients furthermore this increase in
dopaminergic activity this persist
persistence in one to two weeks five to
six weeks and nine to ten weeks after
the pre-pubertal stress and it's also
associated with hyper activity in the
ventral hippocampus both one to two
weeks and five to six weeks after the
pre-pubertal stress we also see a loss
in parvalbumin inter neurons here we see
on the top left breath a loss of
parvalbumin neurons in the center we see
a loss of parental Nets which is a
protective covering of the parvalbumin
neurons and if we look at par mobium in
neurons surrounded with pairing around
low nets on the top-right we see a
substantial and persistent decrease in
both so again stress we think can lead
to increased amygdala activity can also
lead to oxidation
stress is shown by numerous studies by
Kim doe and others which can together
lead to parvalbumin loss in the
hippocampus hyperactivity in the
hippocampus and increased dopaminergic
neuron activity this is normally
counteracted by the medial prefrontal
cortex it can blend the effects of
stress on the basolateral amygdala
however what happens if we interfere
with medial prefrontal cortical function
so what we did is to lesion the pre
limbic prefrontal cortex an area that's
involved in stress regulation five days
before the stress exposure now this
lesion of the pre-olympic prefrontal
cortex was enough by itself to make the
animals more anxious so they're as
anxious as the mam animals pre-pubertal
e with no treatment except pre limbic
lesion now we find that foot shock alone
that was sub threshold for causing
changes in the dopamine system now
caused a substantial activation of
dopaminergic neuron firing and a big
increase in a local motor response to
amphetamine now what about if we do the
stress exposure in the adult rats well
if we give the same combined stress to
young adult rats and then perform
recordings 5 to 6 weeks later what we
find is no change in dopaminergic neuron
activity however if we recorded an
earlier time point just one to two weeks
after stress what we find is just the
opposite
a decrease in dopaminergic neuron
activity but the decrease is now in the
medial VTA the medial VTA projects the
ventral medial stratum that's involved
in motivation and reward so this more
resembles depression than it does it's
Freni now why are pre-pubertal rats more
sensitive with the effects of stress
well during puberty we have a critical
period where the part of albumin neurons
are getting excitatory inputs that are
being made and broken and rearranged as
the animal learns to to
deal with its environment after puberty
their molecular brakes that come into
place that caused these pair inaudible
and that's the form that lock in the
plasticity so that you're not as plastic
after puberty but also prevents the
neurons from damage but you could
actually reopen this critical period by
several interventions and one of them
are aged iechyd inhibitors are histone
deacetylase inhibitors the aged AG
inhibitors can reopen the critical
period so what we did is to give an H
doc inhibitor valproic acid to the adult
animal we gave out Pro acid for 15 days
with the last 10 days giving the
combined stress and what we find is
without bail Pro acid the combined
stress decreased medial dopaminergic
neuron activity but with fel-pro
accosted the combined stress increased
dopaminergic neuron activity and caused
a big increase in them fed amine induced
locomotion furthermore this persists if
we look five to six weeks later we still
see the activation of dopaminergic
neuron firing in the activation of
amphetamine induced locomotion if we
look at part of albumin neurons
interestingly one to two weeks after the
stress we see a loss in parvalbumin
labeling in both a naive and distressed
animals but in the naive animals it
recovers the baseline but in the animals
exposed to valproic acid and stress it
doesn't recover the baseline it stays
low and is maintained at a low level now
the pro AG acid has a number of actions
besides being an H tag inhibitor it also
interferes with GABA also potentiates
gaba
what about if we give a more selective H
that inhibitor well what we used is Saha
that has h tack inhibition properties
but it does not work on the gaba system
and is not a a mood stabilizer and what
we find is that the
ah-hah itself was enough to reopen the
critical period in the adult and
activate dopaminergic neuron firing so
therefore the billet arias impact of
stress combined with factors
predisposing an individual to the impact
of stress we think underlie the
susceptibility to schizophrenia and this
is critically dependent on timing of the
stress exposure to stress during
adolescence can lead to par will be in
the loss in schizophrenia an exposure
during adulthood can lead when the
parvalbumin neurons are protected can
lead to depression and interestingly
schizophrenia and depression both run in
the same families and what we posit is
the reason that they run in the same
families is the common underlying
variable is hyper responsibility to
stress and when this is combined with
stress either during adolescence leading
to schizophrenia or in adulthood it can
lead to depression then the increased
response to stress we think may be
mediated by a failure of the medial
prefrontal cortex to limit the impact of
stress exposure so if we can identify
individuals and intervene early enough
we might be able to prevent the
deleterious effects of stress and the
transition to schizophrenia basically
find children that are a genetic risk
for schizophrenia based on family
history test to see whether they are
hyper responsive distress in the
pre-pubertal period and then teach them
to deal with the stress either by giving
them more social interactions or more
enriched environment or by giving them a
cognitive behavioral therapy where they
can learn how to deal with stress
exposure and then to thank all the
people in my lab who are involved in
this work poly more he developed the
man-animal in my lab Dan Lodge who did a
lot of the work looking at the certain
the circuitry of the mam animal Stan
Florescu and Tony West who looked at
hippocampal modulation of the dopamine
system
Katie Gill who did the work on me novel
gaba drug each one do did the work on
prevention of schizophrenia
Susie sunshine who did a lot of the work
looking at the drug effects on
schizophrenia and sleep it goes gomez
and Jason she did a lot of work looking
at pre-pubertal susceptibility and thank
you very much for your attention thank
you dr. grace for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab Earth for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2019 as a final reminder
our speaker will follow up with any
questions you submitted via email that's
all for now thank you for joining us and
we will see you next time goodbye
[Music]